[Music]
all right uh hello good evening uh
supposed to be good evening right in St
Louis um so this is first my dream my
name is melik C Grand Master mik I go by
by GM mik if you guys will look for
search for any platform like ch.com uh
actually.com is the best platform for me
uh today I want to talk about um uh one
important subject um basically you know
these days everyone jumping to the play
the openings learning this learning that
and pretty much people are kind of um I
would say not ignoring but not paying as
much attention to sort of um other
stages of the game and importantly for
me the common mistake uh what I have
done what I have seen uh from my
students games it's whenever uh like a
kids students it's not even kids
students kind of studying the opening
lines without actually understanding uh
like the connection the setups you know
and um actually the first game I was
going to show you different but it's
okay still I'm planning to play short
two games anyway uh first I'm going to
show you a little bit a game which what
what important part of this game would
be how to understand the structure the
pawn connections so um this game I
played uh many years ago when I was
young and strong and I played uh in a
tournament in Los Angeles
and I played I faced uh Grandmaster
matamores um um I forgot what his
Original Country I think he he know
right now he switch to Spain um um so
anyway we played the short
tournament and I had no idea when never
I met before and I facing before so I
played this my line at that F6 and back
then I was playing some kind of mixed
idea between uh I'm still doing this
sometimes uh idea of grunfeld and
slav and I played this D5 move and uh
like I said I like the idea of mixing
things together and this is what we
called Original SL sled defense you know
when I was young uh when I was having
trouble to play against faneto position
with Bishop on G2 while I was playing
some kind of you know grinfield benoni
BL whatever and that one day I came to
my coach and I said so how to handle
this bishop P it's so annoying I keep
losing my games uh keep having problem
he said why don't you build the CH build
the wall like a great ch wall against
the bishop on G2 and make sure this
bishop never comes to life I'm like wow
interesting solution you know saying
this kind of funny like uh I don't know
if it's appropriate to say that but the
best way for you to to deal with the
threat if you believe it's a threat to
eliminate the threat so I play this D5
move uh I have this position I played it
many times in recent years uh bishop2
castle castle and I play Mo Bishop G4
and one ideas of of schle was to play
Bishop G4 basically since you're posting
the pawns uh already like on this uh you
know like uh you have a chain looking
down straight against the bishop is on
G2 which means you already committing
yourself to put your pawns as a chain uh
towards the one particular direction
which means pretty much whenever you
have a commitment a car commitment
posting the chain meaning like your best
piece by definition supposed to be the
opposite col Bishop I mean question is
what would you do with other brother so
one brother in a good hand what about
the other brother what about this bishop
you know what do you do well in this
case one brother needs to get away
because you know it's like a famous
what's this expression right I mean uh
two people cannot sit on on one horse
right something like that right so you
you can use the one horse for for for to
like uh you know nights something like
that whatever uh but my point is at at
this point unfortunately no matter how
much I love the Bishops you know uh I
must play Bishop G4 to trade my Bishop
for the Knight and so far this is like
very much familiar territory for myself
I have played this many times I have
seen this many times perhaps my opponent
as well and when he plays the3
move from this particular move water I
had to take on F3 right away so I had
take move right away and because why why
I have to let me explain why because
again you came for the bishop G4 you
don't have any retrial point and you are
going to pretty much sacrifice your
Bishop uh for the Knight I mean
sacrifice meaning it's like you're going
to get Traer anyway so he's about to
play KN D2 I mean he's about to play KN
D2 and whenever um I will take on F3
he's going to replace retake on F3 by
the night which means very much I'm
losing my point being there
while if I'll take on F3 at least I'm
going to slow down his natural play I'm
going to make him capture on F3 by the
bishop it's not exactly natural meantime
uh it means he would have a control over
E5 Square extra control which means I
have a chance to play KN D7 let's say
Rook E8 and E5 so this is sort of the
idea game of chess remember this
everyone game of chess require one thing
we call this balance when you give away
like in your life when you give away
something when you lost something you
must gain something back I mean there is
no point for you to lose something in
your life in your game and then get
nothing back it means that it's not
smart
right okay
so yeah and then my opponent when I was
kind of sitting on the chair waiting for
my opponent to recapture on a three by
the bishop then suddenly my opponent
took on a three by the pawn
so this is the thing what uh what we
need to keep asking ourself whenever you
guys studing the opening lines once
again uh these days obviously we have so
much information right we have a chess
base we have a so many other private
databases we have a streams we have a
chest tournament ongoing so much
information and sometimes I mean your
your head is like blowing up right you
know looks like more you know let you
understand I mean earlier I remember
when I was a kid what we had maybe
magazine maybe two magazines you know
and it was easy because like a tiny
magazine you know you get you getting
like you you're studying oh my gosh this
is oh my God I remember I used to
collect the the games you know collect
the games posting them writing down the
games posting some analysis blah blah
blah and then when I grown up I became a
about teenager we had this C informator
you know and then oh my god oh every
three months coming out you I must get
this because you know why because so so
many navali on it you must get this to
to Pro I mean to kind of you know go
with it okay now what we have even worse
we have a computer generation I'm not
sure what's going to be tomorrow now I
remember when I was a
kid uh you know my one of my backgrounds
uh who does who do who doesn't know me
uh thank you by the way Patrick uh yes I
I won this us championship by the way
this is my only maybe not only maybe I'm
still going to get some
national championship on my belt so I
was a kid and I want of the session my
background I I've been trained under uh
ter petran and I still learn so far from
him and pretty much what I'm doing these
days I'm passing knowledge which I
learned from my Teran petran grade to
all my students
so and I remember uh at at some point it
was one of the sessions and petran asked
me okay explain to me tell me how do you
study the opening lights I'm like I show
this to one of my folders I think it was
some something Sicilian and I said oh
listen this is like a I said how many
games you have on your in your whatever
forer is you know I said like I don't
know 50 games and I was so proud
collecting those games from the
magazines from everything and he said
and you remember all those 50
games I'm
like I don't
know probably not then he said so how
many games you remember
then can you give me the any game with
any particular name on
it I'm
like maybe game or maybe two I recall
out of you know my memory and he said ah
you see you don't need to have a 50
games on your on on your whatever folder
you need to have perhaps three maybe
five games top but a you must remember
who played those games the ideas and
names more names is not really important
but what I'm saying is uh you you must
uh you must collect the games of players
who you know personally let's say G
casparo visha Ana kowana aronian the way
how you trust you know someone who you
can trust someone who is more or less
matching your sort of uh type of
play you
know yes this this is the first game
atorus versus uh catch from from us uh
yes San Diego open I I I I call San
Diego open because it was has different
name but I call it because it was played
in San Diego
anyway and since then I I this is what I
follow this is what I do uh with my
students I never sent I never helped my
students I never s to my students like
big files every time whenever I send
something like to file a I am explaining
myself first I'm explain the most
importantly connection between opening
and middle game and B if I'm going to
send something like uh something think
as a as a uh refreshing the memory I
usually in put one two three games
picking like important games games which
I know more or less and then uh
attaching them to the file and here you
go file sent and my my kids my students
will will study that and trust me they
will remember it only like for most
advanced I have a student who is almost
grandmas for instance only for them I do
need like extra work preparing like uh
kind of uh more detailed files uh uh
analysis from Super engine and stuff
like that for level before no need to
have those big big big files because
trust me I'm guarantee you like 80% from
all those files which you have on your
computer from chessel from this from
that all of them they're going to stay
there for a long long time and you won't
be able to touch them same as your books
how many books do you
have question 500 books oh my gosh 500
books that's so cool how many have you
read read five
five so what about those 495 I don't
know you
know all right so when my opponent took
n of three by the pawn first question
you asking
yourself why you haven't seen this move
before I mean you understand you're
playing grandmas you can't really say
Grandmaster does know this position I
mean he plays all his life C4 then that3
come on he's supposed to this position
right why would he took it I mean I
asked myself question I try to find the
answer and you know I I realized there's
nothing particular it's just a move but
whenever you study the opening lines and
for some reason whenever you don't see
this move often it means the move is not
that good I mean whenever a move is not
number one choice or two choice or three
Choice whatever it means there's
something wrong with that move
right again what's wrong well looks like
why it's damaging the POR structure okay
if uh White double his pawns which means
white damaged the pawn structure
question is what they have in right
now they have a bishop paare and yes if
he wants to play some kind of move F4 to
defend I wouldn't say defend I would say
kind of control E5 Square all right but
let me ask you this question so you kind
of understand the concepts the the
idea but you playing not on the white
side you playing on the black side
and uh whenever we talk about the like U
let's say middle game switch to middle I
mean opening switch to Middle game the
fight just started right the fight just
started and whenever you're find it it's
like an arm wrestling you know you're
trying to put the arm on your side right
so ask yourself a question what is your
best part of your
position what is your privilege here and
your privilege here it's better point
porn structure isn't
it so Alex tell me what do you know if I
have better porn structure what's the
general like general advice to do for
situations whenever you have better
Point
structure I I don't actually know now
you
will it's very simple simplify the
position yeah exchange
pieces exchange pieces better end game
absolutely
correct better Pawn structure you know
how we understand structure better or
not it's very simple just close your
eyes I mean first keep your eyes open
big as big as possible and remove every
single piece from the board leave King
and pawns and then close your eyes and
try to visualize what if King and pawns
would that be good end game for black or
white see anything related to the pawn
structure even small changes if you
believe for whatever reason you have
better por structure trade trade
pieces yeah I agree Patrick I mean it's
it's it doesn't see defensive I would
say but it's it's a certainly like kind
of passive in my opinion but again I
wouldn't say necessarily oh this is
defensive or this is passive blah blah
blah blah for me the way how why I call
this not natural because why would you
why would you damage your Pawn structure
what you getting instead again it's like
a why we say chess like in your life
whenever you're going to invest in
something I mean you're definitely is
going to try to understand and calculate
your risk anyway right you don't want to
like invest on something if you don't
know how big or how much risk is going
to be would be so I mean the life it's
like a life balance giving something
take something back to you
so
tra obvious development right
this question to audience questions to
audience live here I mean when we have a
open file and we have it here open file
D which means we need to fight back
right we need to challenge the fight the
the the the
file I have a question is there any
difference between challenging this file
should I challenge it with f Rook or
should I challenge with a
rook yes we are back we always we're not
even back we always here what do you
mean I mean St Lou is always
here should
do why so if you ever Bish
a something like that something like
that
um not even that again definition of
faneto in most of the cases whenever you
have Bishop on D7 it means your play is
supposed to gun towards the whole
thing and your kind of Ideal picture is
to challenge the opposite sides of the
board look how many like I'll give you
multiple example benoni I'll give you
Sicilian Dragon I'll give give you like
a perk many many opening designed for
that Bishop to kind of uh go through it
and pretty much like a put the the whole
like uh I mean pressure on on the whole
board every time whenever you have a
bishop in the game in most except maybe
like King's Indian defense whenever
Center is locked down and whenever like
you have to play towards the king side
any other opening it always goes towards
the queen side now if your game plan
supposed to to be on the queen side it
means your piece is supposed to move
towards the queen
side and you're right this is Vladimir
move Rook fd8 because you already have a
commitment you already committed
yourself to play to play faneto so you
play supposed to be going towards the
queen
side
now since we say our play is supposed to
be towards the queen side how are we
going to organize our play here
any suggestions
here to be honest it's also uh would be
helpful if you're going
to kind of uh get get yourself some sort
of familiarity with this kind of P
structure so this type of POS position
most likely could uh could appear from
something like King's Indian
defense most likely you know it's very
close by Pawn structure and again since
we understand uh this is about like
playing to uh to on the queen side first
question if I'm going to ask you the I
mean in King's Indian defense type of
position the white Pawn is on E2 or E4
could be forever and but in this case
white moved so point is white E Pawn is
not on E2 or E3 it's on
F3 what is the biggest problem for
exactly Vladimir well done but question
is can you tell me how you see your
picture what is the best picture for you
to organize this kind of you know to
cook this things
together the f 7
C5 ah bravo bravo Alex
Bravo you know I think when I was a
kid um like I said in my time we did not
study the games uh by computer by all
the streams blah blah blah um personally
my my book which I had learned King's
Indian defense I learned by watching the
book the games from uh
1953 inter zon tournament in
zorich uh written by brunstein I mean I
think I heard this actually I saw the
second edition by Grand Master Miguel
nidor as well but on that book I mean it
was incredible like uh you know I mean I
would say incredible storage of the
games by by brunstein by RFI I mean by
petran all these guys played Kings
Indian defense
and you know in my opinion again I might
be mistaken but the way how I say it
back then people didn't lie back then
whenever they unpl the game they
actually posted like everything most
most ofly Tru you know because they
wanted to share with the new generation
they mosted like kind of you know to
teach and yes I mean I personally
learned from that book I actually
learned NSO from that book I learned
Kings Indian defense from that book I
mean many many opening lines Queen's com
decline more or less so and I still
remember the ideas the games they know
how they played because I went that I
went through the game like game by game
very
carefully and I went uh game by game
very carefully and this is Incredible
Book by the way
so
97 Knight
C5 Knight B4 I believe one of the ideas
what I saw it was Game of uh revi when
he handled this kind of B3 a A2 B3 C4
Point structure
um I don't remember what's the game like
uh Z bronstein or Z rvi I
forgot um yeah anyway the idea it's very
simple two knights stands on these two
squares you hit the D3 Square on top of
with you also have in mind to play a
like a A7 A5 and A4 and destroy the
whole thing on the queen side you
know which level my opponent I mentioned
L my my opponent was ground M
Matamoras from Ecuador I remember now
from Ecuador back then he then he moved
to
Spain yeah so Rook d8 rook
d8 and now D3 Square almost impossible
to stop to protect you know and uh after
long thinking my my opponent tried to
play an
A3 but it doesn't really like U helps
much because I'm still playing KN D3 so
now I have a simp simple threat of
playing on taking on B2 and if you play
something like Bishop A1 still doesn't
help you because now I take from
here so very much everything is
collapsing so my oppent had to play
something like this and here we go I
trade trade trade I PST my KN back and
now I have like a simply and strong
outpost on C5 you can't even touch my
knight he's like
untouchable
and
then pick up the breakfast why
not and push to by the way this is also
have a threat time to check so he can
have a chance to play F4 and as soon as
the break happens then E5 so clearly you
want to you want to nail this Pawn on on
F3 that's it you secure your knight you
complete your mission then I had to
bring my king to the
game
yeah I think I repeat this once because
I think I was kind of having lower time
on my clock I just wanted to reach move
40 and finally like I I I start to B
here okay very much everything it's
winning here very much every single move
it wins here CB Knight B5 Knight D4 but
in general that general question from uh
from Pure n and understanding the basic
opening
principle which way I should take on B5
by Knight by Pawn by
King yeah Bishop is Bishop was bad I
agree I agree Patrick
yep okay Patrick wants to take on B5 by
the pawn by trying to organize simply
pass Pawn uh like a outside pass Pawn
okay okay fine so that's you think uh
that's what you think you feel you
should be
handling okay I want to see explanation
of uh of J can you can you please
explain to me why by
night so I want to ask a question for
Jared
uh Shrek Shrek and G
right
yes Patrick I get it you're trying to
play CB because obviously you want to
connect your pawns you want to kind of
stick together and you want to then
eventually play perhaps something like
B4 and organize a pass Pawn but you see
question what I have if you play
something like C Tak B5 move and try to
push like a before uh something like
that I think
uh the issue is after you play B4 after
you play ab ab I play King D3 you play
B3 uh I mean the point is my king is
close enough I mean your B Pawn is not
what you
want still wins though is still
winning okay so you that's the only
point so let me explain the most in my
opinion the most proper way for black to
play is to capture with the
Knight because I'm trying to clean the
RO for my king you see this is the basic
end game and in basic end games role of
the king is very important King always
wants to be Advanced so I'm playing uh
here King
D4 I'm going to keep my king to stay in
front of the pawn like in a pawn end
game because King in this case is kind
of cleaner you
know and finally my comes my Pawn comes
forward and my opponent had resign here
again remember in basic end games what
you must remember always try to keep
your king to stay in front of your pawns
because your king supposed to be in
front to help your pawns to move forward
he's sort of cleaner that's why if you
look for this in my opinion most
appropriate way for black to capture
here it was captured by the Knight
because it challenged the king it's
opposition it's a check King has to move
and as soon as king moved then your king
comes forward and brings after him his
Pawn to move forward okay this Al also a
tactical explanation because white
couldn't play King G4 because of N3
check perhaps if if King A4 move would
be available then Patrick I would take
on Fire by the C Pawn you know but again
since I saw tactically King A4 move it's
not available for him meanings I saw I
can play KN C3 move right after which uh
stops King A4 threat uh and attacks the
bishop and my my my Pawn comes as follow
that's
it so next uh game I wanted to share
with
you it's actually happened um few days
ago so first one you see like a kind of
structural changes you see how much
grandmas Matamoros uh um I think one of
his mistakes was he simply uh did not
follow uh the I mean ideas of of the
opening and that's why he got very much
punished so next game uh it's actually
happened like about a week ago maybe
eight days ago and and I was very much
impressed uh it's it's in most uh recent
uh you know tournament in in Mexico uh
and a 20 years old uh junior
Championship incredible Talent uh I mean
Mazi Mark Andrea I mean he's 16 years
old uh he's like I think he's Curr like
25 50 average something like that I
think if he before the event he was 2533
as you see it but after this tournament
I'm sure he's going to K like over
2550 the kid is incredible he's not even
16 yet and he's still wearing some kind
of shorts with kind of you know uh some
kind of you know whatever like a toys
animals on it so I mean he's still kid
yeah seriously he's he's still kid like
a Mickey Mouse or something like that
you know what I'm saying he's like a
clearly like uh he's still like very
much like in in in in his dreams but
I'll tell you what we call this touch
you know with his touch I can I can feel
feel he's clearly going to be like next
2700 player in in France I mean I mean
very soon very soon he's going to hit it
there I'm sure he's going to be like a
France team at some point is going to be
like a team to be scared like imagine
fuja imaginea gra imagine uh this kid is
is growing up and they have another uh
first board 2690 2680 I mean they're
going to have like a board for board
like with very much like
2700s Anyway this kid playing against uh
Ian shito from malova so Ian shito has
uh low rated a little bit compared to uh
2555 for mait and 2533 for uh shito but
shito also were well known because last
year maldovan team had made like a huge
noise uh in Alit in Chennai when they
finished like top 10 top eight something
like that and they there were no GMS in
a team they were all all IMS and they
beat so many top teams including team
Norway with Magnus on
it yeah impressive oh it's super
impressive it's super impressive I think
they were listed like a number 50 sish
in in the rank
list imagine in a man rant rank list if
you listed like a 50 Sunfish and you
jumping and you're getting like a second
place I no not second like a whatever
eth or 10th I mean that's incredible
that's like a right there the story for
you to tell you know and in most
recently like old cup he also was able
to uh to knock down our own uh same
shankland and then he almost knocked
down um white
tashk in in the first round he beat him
with uh not beat him I would say vachik
lost it mostly uh maybe this is for
subject for our next lecture for the for
the endg game
knowledge yeah he only lost on tiebreaks
yes Vladimir he only lost to V I mean to
on tiebreaks to to uh to Avid tashik
anyway so he his in situation for this
tournament was around night he was half
Point
behind I mean you can check with chess
24 and he was playing on the board two
and he sort of needed to play for win
you know uh but once again you
understand whenever you play most
important rounds you always want to play
uh games which you uh opening lines
which you trust most because it's very
difficult for you to to to surprise
someone who is more experienced than you
are so you want to play if if you want
to sort of surprise your opponent at
least play something what you understand
and you played before you trained before
uh so you have some kind of experience
but guess playing like playing something
absolutely out of blue it's always
dangerous even for for uh for for strong
player I remember many many years ago I
played absolutely something out of blue
with without preparation just to
surprise my opponent it was em Tate uh
great emate and uh you know and Emory
responded so well and at some point I
realized uh you know I surprised him but
I also surprised myself and at some
point I realized I might be going down
and I said you know what I off draw
somehow like emry accepted and I was
kind of lucky or maybe opposite he
accepted he offer me draw and them
accept because I couldn't really
understand what's going on honestly I
didn't know what to
do and
um so yeah but again it's it's is I
wasn't agree with you Patrick it's
before this game they both played okay
tournament they both played actually
good tournament obviously p i mean
obviously uh Mazi has a fantastic
tournament it's like probably a tour of
his life um but shito was okay if shitu
wouldn't lose this game if let's
say would win this game I mean things
could get changed change you know anyway
they play this line a little bit
sideline it's a mixed idea between uh
Bishop C5 and Stein's defense because
usually when we play Bishop C5 move this
is like I say original Bishop C5 move
right the idea to kind of support Knight
D4 and trade those Bishops you must do
it with Bishop on B5 only and play
something like
this uh and other Bishop CI we call this
arangil whenever you play something like
um A6 Bishop A4 at F6 Castle U B5 uh
followed by Bishop C5 this a
hungus uh and Stein is which I played
myself many times it's A6 Bishop A4 D6
let's say castle you play Bishop D7 and
very much you do St ideas here to
protect this um uh E5 square with two
knights you know so this line what play
by shito it's combination of everything
a he plays A6 B he plays mishop C5 then
he does B that g E7 but IDE very much
remain the
same now so if5 PA is more or less
secure he's supposed to play here Castle
King side and on Knight D2 he's supposed
to play D6 so very much we have a styish
ideas of holding the E5 Square uh while
your Bishop is on A7 and kind of
pressure the def4 PO I mean it's kind of
interesting I mean to to be honest when
I saw the game in the first the first
place I thought oh my gosh it's
ridiculous what what the heck's going on
I thought this are like complete like a
I mean alha but then when I clicked on
chess Bas uh when I start to look at it
I found like you know people like Guk
some other top GMS have played it and
then I start to get interested of this
line I kind of start to study this line
and I you know I kind of came to
conclusion this actually more more or
less playable line you know so again
this is like position to play played so
many times okay little bit passive for
black but absolutely holdable absolutely
fine for black to
play
instead black plays move
D6 so you
see I mean what what is it is it like uh
bad preparation I think he simply forgot
messed up the move water and why he
messed up the moon water simply because
he had never played this line before he
was trying to surprise the opponent but
he forgot himself the mo he messed up
and Mazi goes straightforward he's a
young he's a kid he's very ambitious and
he has no fear absolutely it doesn't
matter for him who he is facing I mean
he plays chess absolute logical chess a
he goes by principle D5 and by the way
he was showing like a very good opening
knowledge basically for him this opening
was wasn't really like a kind of a for
surprise
D5
take like in famous song Show Me Your
Money I have extra PA what you
got what you
got so black tried to create some
counter playay look at this move
C4 again you know my my my coach one of
my coaches used to said
always try to put the knights on C3 F3
C6 F6 positions every time whenever you
don't put your Knights on those
positions it means it's either
particular opening choice or something
very special but try to always put your
KN on those position I still remember
his voice and I mean you know his his
advice so and that's what Ma does he
simply C4 yeah it is high class move
seriously Patrick this is I I agree I
mean you you're kind of keeping your
cool you know what I'm saying you kind
of remembering everything and you you
think okay then my B9 what's the future
by the way this is another way for you
to understand uh the best piece in the
game is not necessarily your queen in
the game we always say the best piece
it's most advanced piece which means
this is my best piece now next question
does your piece itself do anything in on
it in it no so your piece sort of needs
some support how are you going to have
support if you look for steinet what
stus said fidor even before St fidor
said the strength of the Pawn on the
ability of moving forward Pawn supposed
to move forward Pawn doesn't stay on the
same spot so how do I move my Pawn
forward I eliminate this Pawn how do I
eliminate this Pawn I'm going to bring
my knight to D5 I'm going to attack C7
Pawn step by step
thinking when you cannot see when you
know I usually teach my students this
way when you don't see the whole the
full picture the whole picture the
easier for you to realize and kind of
you know think that way it's always like
a break down the big picture on a small
pieces and that's the way to do
it KN comes here
and once again you see Knight doesn't
get deflected from I mean from not
getting there so if I if I promise to
myself to get myself to D5 right a I'm
going to play this and D I'm not going
to get you know distra by taking a
knight E4
no and my knight the other Knight will
go on4 while this Knight belongs to be
on
D5 and now what well I mean I said a a b
take the pawn and this an incredible
moment you know I guess one of my
weaknesses one of my problems I I love
to sacrifice exchanges when I saw this
game alive I said oh my God he's going
to do like that Rook F5 move and do this
I was kind of uh I saw this idea some
some check some kind of queen
B7 but luckily mait is not catching and
so he knows better than
me and he simply play Cal move C5 so
initially I thought my C5 is kind of
weird because
again when I watched the by the way this
is another advice for everyone I really
hate to use those engines whenever
engine keep telling you how great you
are or how dump you are this engine bar
kills me so usually when I watch these
games like on the live stream I'm trying
to shut down this kind of engine and I
mean I see some uh some engine keep
going uh but I don't really see like
actual evaluation
everything so when he play C5 I kind of
expected move D5
but I I mean uh again I was having
lessons watching on my other computer
this kind of games and uh I I couldn't
be like focusing 100% on the games right
well that's normal for us you know you
you teach and you're doing something on
the computer watching something I mean
it's I think it's normal for me at least
so and then I was wondering what's what
reaction would be I mean I could of
thought he's going to do something crazy
but then look at this
move
I saw this sorry okay I thought you g to
add
something yeah I mean this was
incredible like 96 move uh simple at
strong and after the straight
um you know but this move it
was I mean so annoying I never knew
French people so annoying you know and
then
Oppa More Night it's not like one
hanging I'm going to give you second
night let's take
it and that's what actually truly
incredible
this yeah yeah right Patrick this this
game is incredible game seriously this
game one of those beautiful games and
again this kid is like not even 16 right
15 something I mean not even 16 that's
incredible Talent that's why I'm I'm my
prediction is he's going to be like next
to fujio or something like that I don't
know and um yeah after
this before very
simple and this is really like you know
basically
we convert this
advantage
and we won the
game so funny like white was offering so
much material white was offering so much
stuff and the day they actually got
extra material on the board and they
actually won the game uh again uh I was
so much impressed for this game and you
see the Clear Connection the pure
connection between like middle I mean
opening and the middle game and the end
game so that's how it works because
uh if you don't understand the
connection between your uh play between
your stages then you're going to be in
trouble and again don't try to surprise
your opponents who has a higher level
than you are because you might get lost
by yourself you know it's simply I mean
again even if you try to surprise your
opponent and trying to play something
rare which uh wouldn't be found like on
on your datab basis you still need to
get some
experience
all right any questions audience from
here from from our online audience any
any questions next time we're going to
talk about some other subject for
sure yeah it is creative it is
creative okay then well thank you for
coming uh yes St Louis it's it's a c of
Universe for sure we we we are the best
in the world it's no questions
well if we if we
good yes then I try to maybe focus on
some opening ideas and connection like
this I'll give you more example for
this maybe I will include my on thank
you Patrick thank
you all right
thanks for coming and looking forward to
see you just to check the schedule right
Ben I mean they need to check the
schedule uh stay tuned I mean I'm here
for more than 20 days I'll give you more
excitement so yeah we going Championship
is tomorrow oh yeah open and also we
have like yeah I mean open I mean we
have us Championship coming up but I'll
give my own excitement you
know
right all right right guys have a good
[Applause]
[Music]
one